John how ready were you for the fame
that came with grease on the heels of
Saturday Night Fever then right after
that urban cowboy I mean you were
instantly on top of the world how did
your life change at that point well
fortunately I had the TV series of
welcome back hunter to warm up Vinnie
Barbarino of course so that that made me
a gradient of Fame if you will but I
don't know if anyone's prepared for what
senator fever and grease would do to
your mindset but it it's all good
remember that you you were worried about
Saturday Night Fever and I yes and I
showed it all to you and you guys were
not worried about it well I thought that
I shouldn't play Tony Manero but aside
from that it's no I don't know and would
you guys come and see it we flipped out
it was a after he's finished shooting is
crazy I remember that day yeah I
remember they were instilling a costume
we came to watch it with you and it was
just brilliant you can imagine he's just
well you never say no I mean any movie
that that you present for the first time
who knows what what the outcome will be
so even including grease I mean there
was some variation of interpretations of
how grease would do I think I was the
only one that had confidence in grease
because I had done the play right on
Broadway and on the road so I'd kind of
knew that it Barry yeah